hey it's Pete from geek talk where we
expose stories behind top startups I'm
here today with Neil Capel and Ian white
from sail through and we're gonna talk
about the story behind sail through and
how these guys got started thanks guys
sure so you're both engineers tell me a
little bit more about what we were doing
before sail through well we met probably
eight years ago at this point Neal with
CTO of a company called money media and
I was an engineer that he hired there
and we liked working together and we
worked together on a few different
projects before we started sail through
yeah I think I have to say it's a very
loose definition to call me an engineer
so how did you know it was time to start
your own company your own company like
one was at one of that realization Danya
you know part of what drove the initial
idea was actually you know some
frustrations we'd had with using some of
the different services different api's
and things that were out there you know
I've done a lot of redevelopments over
the time and every single one I'd kind
of wanted to put the marketing in
control of their own efforts and been
like okay and give them the service that
they needed so the engineering could be
freed up for other stuff and it was none
of them none of them could handle what
we would do nothing did what they needed
to be doing none of them really focused
on the end-user either and how would you
say your engineering perspectives
affected the early four
the products I mean it was definitely
the first version of the product the
first thing that we hacked together was
you know started with an API started
like let's make a simple you know
powerful API that developers you know
CTOs will want to use so like you know
in the in the initial stages it was like
let's let's get our like tech friends to
use this service
you know because a simple integration
like you know half a day of development
and they can turn everything over their
marketing team that's like a big win for
a lot of people yeah and what are some
memorable interactions between you two
guys
like in those early days what were your
respective roles like who was doing what
yeah I mean you know I was essentially
the you know the lead developer and you
know Neal was you know both system admin
you know and there was sort of shared
you know product design going on we'd
kick would kick ideas back and forth and
you know try to try to make things a
reality try to you know we'd both be
meeting with customers and so on
directly and trying to turn around those
conversations directly into something
that we would build we did a lot of we
did a lot of custom sort of requests as
it were but only if they would and still
Thursday only if they stayed online with
where we were going with it right
occasionally we do you know go off-topic
a little bit but we really clicked to it
and so we would turn around stuff
very very quickly normally because we've
kind of you know take the shortest route
and go in there and give me what I
needed to do so this split between sales
and si I mean that's humorous but I
guess we all know that everyone does
everything early on and any startup
right any other memorable stories about
sort of the early days who sail through
I mean you know a lot of those early
days are just about you know alerts and
problems that any would you know fix in
the nick of time I mean we'd have that
experience of actually like waking up in
the middle of the night right before the
alert goes off like first Neal had this
and then after I went on the alerts I
started having the same the same
experience I don't know whether it was
some kind of like you know telepathic
communion with the system or a
premonition yeah I say premonition for
sure I totally woke you up just before
and you'd be like yeah something the
alert would go what were some of the
challenges early on like over your
biggest challenges as we started to like
on board customers and your building
stuff and you know it seems small from a
technical perspective you know we had a
rapidly evolving product with really we
were trying out all kinds of different
ideas different different features you
know really it was a moving target so
trying to keep things sort of flexible
and as as simple as possible and at the
same time scaling and you know dealing
with you know bringing on more and more
customers and supporting the load you
know sometimes those things can be can
be in tension with each other you know
you don't necessarily want to
prematurely optimize against a
particular use case that might actually
change
months down the road you know now we
have a lot more resources and we're a
lot more sort of disciplined or
methodical about how you know changes to
the product take place but back then in
the in the early days you know it was
sort of the Wild West
juggling their juggling it all in our
heads we didn't have many service yeah I
ran the whole thing on one box for a
very long time we actually own one box I
know you're bad yeah it wasn't a color
it was in a coal oh it was it was just
one smoke box yeah it was smoking I
would think when it was when at the
decommission we should have brought in
the evening I don't know why we didn't
and you lean the officers like a flag in
it was something we only be commissioned
it like a year year and a half ago it
was still like sending mail for us like
you know it was just a mail server for a
little while but yeah I don't know what
happened to that box we really should
bring it on the wall I know who's the
other thing as well that we went from
you know early days of really I mean I
was at my sequel die hard you know and
we went from the early days you know
being trying to horror something scale
and my support inside of it and that was
when a lot more of the document oriented
databases were coming out and everything
was happening so it was we you know we
moved up we were one of the early
converts but you know tomando yeah what
would you say the engineering culture is
like here I think everybody here really
believes in the product that we have I
think everybody you know responds to the
fact that so many different clients are
using our product they're you know
integrating with our API building cool
things on top of our own language you
know that's that's exciting for people
and I think people go to work every day
like excited to build on top of like
build a platform that people are
building on top of you know we we spend
a lot of time as a team you know not
just in the office but out of the office
you know because we we genuinely like
and respect each other and
and it's it's just one of the most fun
and unique crew people that I've ever
met in my life yeah I think I mean it's
a hard working environment but at the
same time the you know the whole culture
of sail through is the entire company is
really that you know the life is too
short to not like your colleagues yeah I
mean you know you've really got to get
along and as the in says would go
through you know the tough and the fun
parts but it we they everyone hangs out
I mean you know you know it's a good we
really do have sort of a no [ __ ]
culture what about like as the company's
scaled one thing that I do with career
coaching with engineers is teach them
about leadership skills like how do you
feel about managing a team and how did
you learn like what are your best tips
to engineers out there who might be
interested in moving into positions of
leadership because you know a lot of us
engineers aren't always great at that
sort of stuff by nature any thoughts
there engineer's one I mean the thing I
would say is they gonna decide what they
want to be whether they want to be a
manager or they want to be an
engineering purely engineering and and I
think they should make that public you
know to their in in their environment
because its intends to be people will
sort of as you've grow through your
career put you in management if you
don't want to be in it that's absolutely
fine and needs to be said because you
know otherwise people will start to
position in and and manages that other
companies will start to position people
into those positions and because the
engineer doesn't want to lose their job
they're kind of like okay I'll go along
with it
but if you don't want to be in that
field you're not gonna be successful so
you've got to know what you want to be
and actually make sure that you follow
that path because if you're finding the
wrong path you are not set up for
success it's like we make sure that we
know our engineers if they want to be a
manager and if they don't want to be a
manager then we'll make sure that we can
reward them and compensate differently
but also have the management come in the
other thing I would say is that you know
coaches are brilliant I mean having
management training coaching all kinds
of aspects is you know it's a part of
human growth and I think that needs to
happen for everyone if you want to
continue to you know evolve and be
better at what you do and you know
getting advice from people is the best
thing in there yep cool well best of
luck can't wait to see what the company
goes and yeah I mean I've met your
engineer sir awesome so you guys have
build a great team and excited to see
where it goes